well it was one of the biggest questions
of the weekend could
allegiant stadiums support a large event
without
major issues revolving around traffic
and parking
many of you say no and now there are
concerns about the upcoming football
season
madison kimbrough spoke to county
commissioners about those issues
from garth brooks to the concacaf gold
cup final on sunday
allegiant stadium has already housed a
couple of huge events
but with that comes concern as people
feel there isn't enough parking
making it very hard to get in and out of
the stadium with ease
it just did seem like they were just
woefully underprepared
to handle a group of people that large
which is just really absurd we had about
four ubers cancel on us it definitely
is made me think twice about going i
am a little bit concerned because
the parking is expensive there clark
county commissioner michael naft says
there is room for improvement
and like any new venue it will take some
time this is a brand new stadium
so the way finding could continue to be
improved the signage will continue to be
improved
both personnel from law enforcement who
are on the ground helping with traffic
control to
county staff that's on the ground to
most prominently stadium staff whose job
it is to help direct people in
they're all getting continuously trained
as for the raiders games this fall
naf says there will be a two dollar bus
service starting on august 14th for the
preseason
we worked with the rtc they launched the
raiders express routes those are routes
that launch from
all different corners of the valley
those are going to be on game days it's
one reason why i'm optimistic about the
game day experience
we'll see preseason right around the
corner that was madison kimbrough
reporting